hello everyone and welcome to an
incredibly exciting game from round one
of yesterday's Pro chess League it is
Ireland's first women International
Master at Trisha Kane morala versus uh
the legend himself former 2800 player
Shakir mamiyaro with the peak rating of
2820 and uh former world number two
second only to Magnus Carlson it's it's
quite a match up the difference in
rating is like 600 rating points but the
game here is absolutely stunning and
it's absolutely incredible uh how uh how
how Trisha basically dominates mamidyar
of for the entire game especially his
light core Bishop be very focused on my
Majora's light Square Bishop as the game
progresses so that being said let's
check out what happened here uh Trisha
with the white pieces opens with Pawn to
D4 we have Knight to F6 by Shakir C for
B6 Knight the C3 and Bishop to B7 uh we
have Knight to F3 and Shakira once the
finquet of his other Bishop as well goes
for G 6 we have Pawn to D5 grabbing more
space in the center as Shah allowed it
Bishop to G7 and now grabbing more space
in the center with E4 we have castles
and now Bishop to D3 upon the E6 Shakira
challenges the the Central Pawn
structure and of course uh she just
castles we have Pawn to D6 and
interestingly the position has been
reached before and uh Trisha definitely
did her homework on this one because
this position has been reached three
times and in all of the three games the
player with the black pieces with
Shakira mamidaro so I believe uh she was
still within her preparation
mamidaro had it against the Timur he had
it against Boris girlfriend and also
against Levon aronian and the moves that
were played here are Bishop to C2 Rook
to E1 and also Pawn to H3 she goes for
Pawn to H3 uh which is the move uh I'm a
meter of head against the body's
girlfriend and interestingly maminjarov
won all the three games that I've
mentioned so
knows this position very very well with
the black pieces and again in the game
against gelfand uh mamidaro played Rook
to E8 but here uh he goes Knight B to D7
and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new game
so uh Trisha continues developing Bishop
to E3 we have rooked the E8 and now
Queen to D2 We have knighted the C5 now
going after the uh Bishop on uh D3
Bishop back to C2 and now just e
captures and D5 you could also consider
A5 to prevent that pawn to B4 move uh
but Mama jar has a different plan
cappers on D5 we have e captures on D5
and now just Knight seat to E4 forcing
some traits here as the queen on D2 is
uh attacked so here we have Knight
captures on e4 Knight captures Bishop
captures an e for Rook captures and now
just Rook 8 to C1 and the bishop still
not looking all that great on B7 this
this is a fine Bishop but this bishop
not that much it doesn't really have any
uh place on A6 one thing you could do is
bring it back to C8 and then shift it
over to F5 so here we have Queen to F6
preparing to bring the other Rook into
the game and pawn to B3 as the B2 Pawn
is hanging now so Pawn to 3 and now Rook
8 to E8 we have Bishop to G5 now
challenging the queen queen to F5 and
now Rook after E1 she's offering um a
trade of Rooks along the E file Ponte H5
and now Rook captures on e4 we have Rook
captures on e4 and I'll just Rook the E1
just trading material uh Bishop the ca
Chuck knows that he needs to do
something about this light Square Bishop
so Bishop to C8 and now uh this gives uh
Trisha an idea Bishop to d8 going after
the week backwards C7 pawn and uh how
can how can Mama play this now it's not
impossible to defend the pawn you could
just capture an E1 with Chuck by Queen
D7 but this is easier said than done
because let's say Rook captures anyone
check Queen captures and now you go
Queen back to D7 uh Queen to E7 will
follow and now there's really nothing
better than to trade uh Queen captures
Bishop captures and now Bishop to F5
okay let's say mommy diary goes after
the the queen side Pawns structure and
he will win at least one Pawn but that's
all there is like a king to F1 let's say
Bishop to B1 she can play A3 and after
Bishop day two going after the B3 Pawn
she's gonna play Knight to D2 and now
the only way to win a material here is
to trade the bishop for Knight but once
you trade the the bishop for knight uh
we are left with Bishops of opposite
color let's say king king T2 Bishop
characters King characters Bishop
captures on B3 the king will defend the
C4 pawn and okay momidara will be up
upon but it's Bishops of opposite color
and not much to look forward to here so
uh shaft knows that if he plays that
it's most likely a draw so he goes back
Bishop to fade it's a very tricky movie
to defend the C7 Pawn uh via tactic
because if you capture now then shocking
just straight here Rook captures Queen
captures and play Queen D7 and the
bishop is now trapped and if you go
Bishop here then Queen to B7 again traps
the bishop so instead after Bishop to f8
she plays Knight the D4 attacks the
queen on F5 Rook capture Sunny one with
check Queen capture Sunny one and now
Queen to D7 notice how the bishop is
still unable to uh to enter the game uh
Bishop back to F6 and now Pawn to A6 now
mumbiro wants to play B5 and um oh well
create some chances on the queen side
maybe even allow the bishop to be
developed via that Queen side Knight the
C6 now going after that E7 square and
now Bishop to B7 mama would be the
happiest man on the planet if he could
just trade this bishop for Knight but of
course Trisha does not allow this Knight
back to D4 we have B5 and now Queen to
E2 adding a more support to that C4 Pawn
B captures B captures and queen to A4
now putting pressure on C4 and A2 but
her Queen is nicely defending both of
those uh pawns and here she plays Queen
to B2 attacks the bishop on B7 which is
also a mistake here but uh it's a
convincing one as shock there does not
pick up on it he plays Spawn to C5 she
he just counters with an attack on her
Knight on D4 but uh the way to play this
is actually just to play uh Queen
captures on C4 you give up the bishop
here but it's only temporarily because
after Queen captures now you take the
bishop on F6 how do you do that Queen to
C1 check only move King H2 and now Queen
to F4 check will pick up the bishop on
F6 King to G1 Queen captures also the
Knight is hanging so this would be very
good for shock there but uh she
convinced him that's not possible he
plays Pawn to C5 and now she plays
Knight back to F3 which is incredible as
it again allows Queen captures on C4
with the same idea Queen C1 check Queen
a four check Queen captures Bishop but
uh Shakira misses it again and he plays
Queen to B4 he offers the queen trade
and she declines Queen back to E2 keeps
an eye on the C4 Pawn we have Queen to
B1 with check King to H2 and now Queen
to F5
attacking the bishop on F6 Bishop back
to H4 now re-maneuvering the bishop to
G3 to put pressure on that uh uh D6 Pawn
but also the the bishop is very nice
here keeping an end at F6 Square so
Bishop the C8 chocolate are still
without a way of actually developing or
doing something with the light Square
Bishop uh Queen to E8 now just
threatening to to win the game with
Bishop to E7 so Queen to D7 by shock and
now Queen back to E2 shock their place
uh Pawn to A5 now maybe you could uh put
a threat uh with a move like Bishop to
A6 but Knight to D2 she says Nope the C4
Pawn will be very well defended at all
times Queen back to F5 and now Knight
back to E4 now controlling that F6
square but also putting pressure on the
D6 Pawn so here we have Bishop to A6
putting pressure on the C4 pawn and uh
there are a lot of moves you could play
here she goes for Knight to F6 with
check King to G7 and Knight the E8 with
check shock repeats King G8 and she
repeats Knight to F6 check King to G7
Knight 38 with check and now King the h8
shock not ready to call it a day with a
repetition of moves uh he wants to keep
the game going and place King to h8 and
now he gives her a completely winning
position uh but uh both of them are now
in time travel she misses it she plays a
fine move Queen to beat you with check
but the way to play this is Bishop to F6
with the check the problem is now after
King to H7 she just has to play Bishop
to beat you and this is the only move
that wins so uh pretty tricky one to
find but now the problem is there's no
no move you can play here for black
whatever you try let's say you even pick
up the C4 Pawn like the queen to F or
check King to G1 and Bishop captures on
C4 attacks the White Queen just Queen to
E1 and there's no defense against all of
the threats because Knight to F6 check
will be deadly and then if the King goes
to H6 Bishop the C1 will just pick up
the queen on F4 so there's really
nothing you can do with Bishop capture
here you're just gonna play Knight to F6
check now King H6 Bishop C1 wins the
queen and of course if you go to G7 the
Knight captures on H7 check will pick up
the queen on F4 but this is only one of
the lines uh all of the lines are
winning after Bishop to F6 with check
but you have to see uh Bishop to B2 and
everything that follows she played Queen
to beat you with check which is also
very nice for white but it allows this
very stubborn defense with Ponte F6 okay
Bishop captures on F6 with check King to
G8 and now Bishop to H4 now the bishop
has to be very careful otherwise Queen
to G7 might just end up with Checkmate
Bishop captures on C4 we have Knight to
F6 with check King the F7 now Queen to
B7 with check the king hunt begins
Bishop to E7 only move and now we have
Knight the G8 she offers the Knight for
Queen captures an E7 uh but uh truth be
told that that's the best mamidarov can
hope for he has to go for this and then
after Queen captures an E7 just Queen to
E5 with check and okay captures captures
and it's Bishops of opposite color
should be should be a draw even D6 just
Bishop to B5 the D7 square is covered
you have nothing to worry about here but
instead after Knight the G8 with checked
shock blade Queen to E5 with check
Bishop to G3 and now uh there are a
couple moves he he can play but the
position is bad for him however he
played Bishop captures on D5 we reached
the position from the thumbnail and now
yes his Queen is saying but also her
Queen is hanging on B7 uh problem for
him is that now she is completely
winning here but she has to play a very
very specific move uh in in Big Time
trouble uh so feel free to pause the
video and to win the game for Trisha
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that only
thing that's needed is one little check
and shock can resign and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is night the H6 with check if she found
this move or rather Hatchi found this
move uh the game would be over uh
because there is no move you can make if
you if you put the King on dark squares
then Bishop captures Queen on E5 will
come with check and then you're just up
a queen you cannot go to G8 so only
squares you have available are E6 E8 and
f8 and regardless of where you put the
king if King to E6 then Queen C8 check
next move you pick up the black queen if
you go here again just a nice check you
pick up the queen and of course if you
go here just a nice check and you will
pick up the queen on the next move but
uh she was in in severe time travel
after Bishop captures on D5 she trusted
the former 2800 she played Bishop
captures on E5 which seems like okay you
can still just trade and at least you'll
get a draw but the problem is she also
blundered the piece now because
mamidarov just captured on B7 and now
her Bishop is hanging and also her
Knight is hanging and she plays Knight
captures on E7 other moves don't help uh
and here a Shakira just played the D
captures on E5 and he was in this
position on move 51 that Trisha Kanye
marala resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here if you if
you look at it carefully all of the
squares that the Knight can go to are
covered by either the the king the pawn
or the bishop and here the Knight is
just trapped on the next move whatever
she plays shock will pick up the Knight
and then he will be up a full Bishop so
absolutely incredible game where uh
first mamadarov had that chance it was a
it was a very very interesting game
where she was uh completely dominant she
she kept controlling that light Square
Bishop for the entire game and then she
gave mamidorov an opportunity for this
sort of temporary Bishop sacrifice if
Queen captures on C4 was found followed
by Queen C1 check Queen and four and
queen to F6 but then he missed it and
then she had an opportunity where she
could have gone for that idea with
Knight to F6 um
uh with uh here uh with Bishop to F6
checkpoint by Bishop to B2 again
absolutely incredible line and then uh
in the end uh just a nice uh uh uh here
after Bishop captures on D5 just Knight
the H6 with the check yes you are down a
few seconds on the clock both of your
Queens are hanging uh but if you can
move your queen with Trek and Knight to
H6 would allow just that uh
unfortunately for her the the game was
not played out until the very end uh in
in her favor but uh very nicely done uh
the this weird uh sort of a queen's
Indian setup my major went for where he
crushed the incredibly strong Grand
Masters like what his girlfriend and
Timur grev she outplayed him uh in the
line but she just couldn't pull through
to the rest of the game so great game by
her uh like I said first Irish woman
International Master we'll see will she
see how she does in the rest of the pro
chess League uh but this one goes to at
the former 2800 Charlie uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it and congratulations once again to
those of you who solved this position I
would like to thank Kenneth Frazier the
back with CDs for trade Ricky black and
cash Johnson for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the protest
league and whatever else happens in the
Chess World uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day